welcome students faculty alumni and
special guests to the USA TODAY's dia
for Carnaval my name is Eric with Jeremy
undergraduate student senate actually
thank you all for being here today
several years ago the Student Senate in
collaboration with the USA Today Rock
our campus began this leadership program
which provides free daily printed copies
in the u.s. a New York Times and it's
worth goes to that department email in
order to promote this program about 18
months ago the Student Senate for the
help of the USDA and later the
temperature business through the duck
people help the people of Holland
speaker series we can work from this
video form one of my favorite things on
burning power is that the student or the
bishop the university with everything in
its power to make their reality over the
past 18 months the Student Senate has
received tremendous support for both the
Tepper School of Business and the
university administration has a whole
before me in this room I've just let her
sleep enemy fire speaks and the
particular routine full of public we're
at Ascot Street from the USA today do
all
from the environment diversity
international initiatives president
Cohen is a driving force in company car
to develop become one of those
accessories diversity my limited
interaction president Boehm
I have put the nervousness actually tell
others a tremendous listener and
campaign first minutes president Cohen
is well respected by the undergraduate
student Senate the entire student body
and the campus community as well please
help me in welcoming president
thank you not an introduction their
great leadership
it really is our pleasure
for Cardinal closeness I'm going because
this institution program but because it
brings our best organization great
senior before I read I did good
can you see their media reporter for the
money section and you see today you're
chasing one of the most read visits
journalist in earth these looked at
their speaker since 1994 covering
everything from the rabbit rise of the
Internet to the ongoing globalization of
their TV business
and lately he's been spending a lot of
time covering the Hollywood register
people talking the CEO one of the
largest there was successful business
organizations the adults history with
its roots in Thomas Edison's electric
company GD is now more than a century
old over even eternity well the
diversity and in my turning around
GE has been a transition almost of the
day open sores
the innovation in its products and
processes its inclusion in the success
of GV as an aspen that consumers Jesus
health care with media security energy
attracts classes many markets and runs
his organization Jesus reset the state
support management pictures of lettuce
attention to operational excellence
this led approached the city making my
consistent focus on building the skills
talents no company had work but
assaultive energy has continues to do
just why I was missing named the world's
most admired company both pleasure
magazine in the Financial Times veggies
that G success throughout the years
certainly it's been strongly and
creatively in jeopardy and is a superb
leader energy tradition it's been twice
as when the world's best CEOs my heroes
magazine attractive college and partner
vertices MBA definitely join G pre-1982
Isaac with me through where is the
vision is school she served officially
became CEO of GE for days for everyone
2001 so to say something the same you
know something about managing the face
of change or doesn't understand it
indeed further these to me in welcoming
they say cake
thank you very much thank you all for
showing up tonight all they had to do is
study for exams David so you know they
think they're gonna find answers here
we'll find out well I'm fixing this it's
fascinating to me people talk about
their starts in business and you went to
Dartmouth you went to Harvard but I have
a thing that the most important
experience you had was at Duncan Hines
marketing choice Tunisia brownies can
you explain to the audience why you know
I when I graduated from college in 1978
I thought I wanted to go to business
school but I wanted to work for a little
while so I end up working for Procter
and Gamble for about 18 months and so I
showed up and I was on the Duncan Hines
brownie mix brand a bullpen with maybe
four desks and the desk right next to me
was Steve Ballmer and so Steve Ballmer
and I have been friends for 30 years and
we were probably voted the two employees
least likely to succeed Paula for
Creepers I can't tell you how much sleep
we got every night or you know things
like that but Steve and I have been
great pals for that period of time and
there was no secret ingredient in those
brands I don't think so I'm not gonna go
there great well this is an interesting
time of year to be talking because we're
it's right at the end of the year
tomorrow you can be speaking to some
Wall Street analysts next month GE has
its retreat in Boca to executives what's
your message going to be you know I
would say is it in terms of how we think
about the company today be zippy what's
going on in the world and our investors
but you know what we basically a voice
position the company to be as a safe and
reliable growth company so if you think
about what you read in the USA Today in
terms of what's going on in the world
there's there's really kind of three big
themes you know one is that the US
housing market is in retreat and the US
consumers under real stress because of
that that's the theme number one theme
number two is the global growth has
never been healthier in fact I've been
in business for probably thirty years
and I've never seen the time in my
career where the global economy is less
related
to the US economy that is a which is I
think generally good thing not a bad
thing so the global economy is moving at
an accelerating pace in a positive and
then the third thing is that there was a
whole series of what I would call
synthetic debt vehicles that just didn't
work
collateralized debt obligations Syd's
it's just a liquidity bubble you know
it's probably the fourth or fifth one
I've seen in 25 years they're ugly when
they end what you're seeing right now
isn't the way business is supposed to
work but it's not the last time you'll
see it and it's not the first one that
I've seen so what we try to tell
investors is that in that construct this
is a company that can still grow
earnings 10% can still generate high
returns because of the diversity of what
we have because of the strength of our
businesses and and the quality of the
risk management we have inside the
company now the one thing that's going
to carry our company that'll be a theme
tomorrow that will also be a theme when
we pull our business managers together
is globalization 2007 for the first time
in the history of GE will have more
revenues outside the United States
then we'll have inside the United States
our business outside the United States
will grow between 15 and 20 percent next
year you know we're a one hundred
seventy two billion dollar company it's
a hundred twenty-five years old and in
2008 with the US economy growing at
one-and-a-half percent we'll grow
revenue by fifteen percent 15 percent
because we're in the right places with
the right products at the right time so
but the management team it's how do you
know how do you take a quintessential
American company and even though 1/3 of
the people in the room will have 9 US
passports and make them courageous and
bold and tell them that no matter where
we are we're not good enough we got to
get better and we got to get more global
we got to do it now we can't we can't
wait so domestically you're not
projecting a recession you know we use
the hard way dude guys don't be an
economist if you're a CEO in other words
there'll be people on CNBC everybody you
know everybody will be listening to what
I say tomorrow and look I got like B's
in economics you know you say holy cow
holy you knew right
you know CEOs are lousy economists I
take what the world thinks the world
basically pigs
the US GDP next year that's somewhere
between one and a half and two and a
half percent coming out of we had a mini
recession let's say in 2001 2002 it's
very minor the last four or five years
been for two you know three to four to
four and a half percent so one and a
half is gonna be slower but basically us
is in full employment you know there's a
interest rates are coming down rapidly
David there's a this doesn't have to be
recession in the u.s. if everybody keeps
their wits and the fed that's what it
can do and things like that I just think
it'll be a real slow down because
housing is really going to you know in
50 years the median house in the United
States has never declined it will able
to recline in o7 they'll probably
decline in ohwait and might decline in
o.9 know you're not an economist you
rely on a lot of people to give you
advice and a company that you generate
170 billion in revenues the year
what's your sniff test too so that you
can't be an expert in everything how do
you know when you're getting good
information well you know first thing is
I have things I really watch you know in
other words I I watch rail loadings in
the United States i watch trailer
rentals i watch you know consumer
delinquencies i get these things every
day so I have I have probably a dozen
statistics that I've found over time our
leading indicators of of what's going on
number one number two David you know I
don't let anybody including myself
nobody in gee he's on a for-profit
public board but I encourage all of us
to be on not-for-profit boards hospital
boards things like that I'm at the board
in the New York the joined three years
ago so I get a lot of you know even
though I didn't get A's in economics I
rubbed shoulders but the people who got
A's in economics at least once a month
and things like that so I get I get that
kind of coming my way and I I kind of
stir it all up in terms of how it feels
and and and you know talk to the board
and that's my big decision the other
thing I would say David is that the only
way to run a company like G of our size
and mass everything is bad news has to
travel as fast as good news and you have
to have a management team in a culture
where bad news you know people are
trained to give you bad news on losses
bad news
on what's going on in markets you know I
for instance I got you know I I get a
constant flow of information that's both
good and bad and you know that's what
you want your management team to do so
you get all that coming at you and you
can make a pretty clear set of
expectations you know but it's you know
it's it's a it's a tough year to predict
you know right the economy right now
because you know our appliance business
that gets sold through the contract
Channel you know what it's going to have
a very tough year next year and there's
just no two ways about it
it's gonna have a very tough year at the
same time we're probably the second
biggest wind turbine manufacturer in the
world it's about a six billion dollar we
are sold out throw ten so you can't
paint anything with one brush you know
you have to have some guys that you're
saying get more capacity invest more
let's get more supply and another team
you know right next to him you're saying
hey watch your risk watch your cost
don't get overexposed because and it
makes the time we're in right now I
think a little bit more fluid than
almost any time I can I can remember
yeah when the company gets to be as big
as yours you suffer from the law of
large numbers right it's just kids you
have to grow that much more for to be
meaningful is there any logic in
splitting up the company you know look
we've sold even since I've been CEO in
the last five years we've sold forty
percent of our revenue so you know what
I would say is that we're a company that
always has to refresh itself and I think
we should always be very tough-minded
about what fits and what doesn't fit so
I think that's fair game you know but at
the same token we try to position
ourselves and big themes where size is
an advantage and not a disadvantage and
and where we can use the girth the
breadth and the depth of the company to
be successful so we've kind of picked
six big themes where I think we can use
the Towton of the company the first one
is infrastructure infrastructure
technology you know this is energy water
oil and gas things like that that's a
big broad hi-tech that's a seventy
billion dollar business that will grow
15% a year for the next five years now
we're not two-bit you know that's a
business we're small people
need not apply you know if you're a
little 500 you know I fell words wrong
but don't take me too seriously I'll
just throw around it I don't you feel
like I'm but a small little 100 or 200
million dollar company isn't gonna be a
winner in infrastructure so emerging
markets you know thirty two billion
dollars for companies in emerging
markets
this is China India Turkey Eastern
Europe Russia Latin America that's going
to pull the whole company along so we're
positioned in these big themes that
allow the company to grow and you know
look our incremental growth next year
will be twenty billion dollars so we're
growing a company each year bigger than
Nike bigger than a lot of companies but
you can only do that if you make size
and advantage and not let it be a
disadvantage
one thing that interested me though
because I cover the media business I saw
a little bit of this when we're Doc
started to watch his Fox Business
Network and was buying Dow Jones
question occurs to me is how do you
compete with someone who feels like he's
on a mission from God you know it's a
great question I think I mean you know
he went out and bought Dow Jones you
could have bought Dow Jones it's it's
it's a it's a great question because you
know look I would say if anybody you
should admire in the business world it's
Rupert Murdoch you know in other words I
I'm a rabid competitor with Rupert you
know I I want to beat him so badly I
can't even describe it but at the same
time when I Drive home at night I say
this is one of the real guys I've ever
met that I have admits admiration for
and he fundamentally you know look I I
worry about investors and when I show
them one I'm worried about investors he
looks at the when he's chairman Warren
says hello investor are you doing today
you know so you've got to have you've
got to have some disciplines about it
that maybe he couldn't always have now
you know in our case when I looked at
when I looked at Dow Jones you know they
but there wasn't one person in the
entirety of GE that knew a god darn
thing about running a newspaper not one
so we're not going to we're not
pay five billion dollars for The Wall
Street Journal when we have no domain no
expertise just because he is no thank
you
and when it comes to CNBC competing
against Fox Business News we're gonna
try to crush them in other words we
won't spare any expense we won't we
won't we won't try to do anything other
than totally beat them and I just view
those as two different decisions right
you know I we've had a long association
with Dow Jones The Wall Street Journal
we hope it would continue if it doesn't
then we'll work with us a or will work
with Reuters or we'll work with somebody
else but you know so I put them in two
different camps right and and so you
know for me when when we want to win
I've got as many tools as Rupert does
and maybe then some but when it comes to
paying a lot he probably did more than I
so where do you see your home runs this
coming year you mentioned that wind
turbines is a big business for you a lot
of the ecological areas but what are
some other area infrastructure huge
emerging markets huge unbelievable
environmental technology what we call
ecomagination wind solar biomass
batteries water desalination growing 25%
a year things are a few about
demographics our healthcare business
early health still has tremendous
tailwind and I would say the did you
know kind of digital world whether it's
an entertainment or healthcare I think
those are the four or five things that
are really going to provide tremendous
amount of growth for us even in a
slowing us economy in 2000 and 2008 so
you're moving to the environmental
business I mean you were one of the
first who took a pretty bold stand in
going green was that strictly a moral
decision was it strictly a business
decision
how would you characterize that I'd say
it's more a business decision than a
moral decision you know we were
doing business reviews in 2003 or 2004
and again one of the advantages of GE is
that I can look across multiple
businesses and try to see what big
trends are so when I spoke to our energy
business our rail business or appliance
business really cross a bunch of
different businesses they are all
working on fuel efficiency conservation
and greenhouse gas emission reduction so
you know our team got together and said
you know this is going to be maybe a big
theme let's let's really study it so we
put together team that went to study the
science of of global warming we put
together team that wins studied kind of
the public policy of global warming we
put together team that went to study how
our customers felt about greenhouse gas
emission reduction efficiency and this
is what oil was a twenty or twenty five
dollars a barrel so you know it's not
where it is today where it's even more
trendy and I think we came to the
conclusion that global warming is a
technical fact that that we felt like
public perception was changing we felt
like it wasn't completely popular with
our customers but they wanted some
leadership they wanted some positions to
be taken and so we launched it in 2005
overko ecomagination but we wanted to
make it very substantive so basically we
committed to a certain level of
technology we committed to having a
certain level of customer engagement we
can commit it to hard revenue numbers
and we committed to reducing our own
carbon footprint by one percent a year
so we did all those things at the same
time and you know in that time period
the world's kind of come our way you
know there's about a 80 percent overlap
between energy efficiency and greenhouse
gas emission reduction so as oils gone
up it's been a natural together and look
I think Society has just changed its
mind about the environment in the US and
around the world and I've learned a long
time ago that when society changes its
mine business better get on board get
ahead of it or you don't you you get
crushed by it
and so you you know whether it's on CEO
comp or energy or anything at like
you know you better get ahead of it if
you want to be now I'm also somebody
does believe that companies for CEO
should have hobbies you know in other
words I want the company to have a great
reputation but if this was only about
reputation I wouldn't have done it you
know my name's not above the door
it's GE I work for investors and III
really totally believe that our
reputation first and foremost comes from
being a great executing a high
performance company and this extent to
which we can do things by solving
societal problems that also leave our
reputation so be it but I wouldn't have
taken this public as saying if I didn't
think it was pro investor first and
foremost how about the administration as
President Bush doing enough for the
environment look I think President Bush
understands it I think in the last year
that he's got you know getting something
done in energy in the environment are
things he'd like to do but again I think
it's going to be a big debate in the
election and you know just it'll this
debate will go forward and look I run
the company I run GE assuming that it's
a question of when and not if we get
carbon caps of some kind there's some
kind of cap and trade I don't know if
that's going to be oh nine oh eight oh
you know ten eleven but it's going to
happen and I want GE to be positioned
for it well since today's the day that I
think Al Gore gets his a Nobel Peace
Prize he favors a carbon tax what do you
think of is intent wait you know what I
would say David is that there's you know
I'm a member of a group called the u.s.
Climate Action Partnership which is a
bunch of companies and NGOs that really
have banded together to try to be a
catalyst for change and our position
paper really is about a cap-and-trade
system at the end of the day I think
there should be a real dialogue between
tax and cap-and-trade and things like
that I mean there are there are certain
things that something called a ta X
makes it a little bit more controversial
you know their market systems but I
think that there should be a market for
carbon there should be an economic that
can be delivered to a cap-and-trade it
also can be delivered with attacks and
if you have a real market mechanism that
can measure these investments
then innovation and technology will take
root but if you're a utility CEO today
let's make sure any one of you could be
a utility CEO and let's say you're 58
years old and your company might be
worth twenty billion dollars and you
have to make a decision to invest in
nuclear power today it's a hard decision
you know it's a three billion dollar
project if you're 58 it's gonna come
online by the time your long retired you
know if you look at the most profitable
energy asset in the USA it's a nuclear
power plant they're all 30 years old
they've been fully depreciated you can
price off the marginal cost of gas your
cost is fundamentally zero these make a
boatload of money the one thing they all
have in common as they were started by
CEOs that all got fired okay everybody
that made that original decision got it
so that's the decision and with no price
for carbon why would anybody take that
kind of risk that makes a 50-year
decision based on you know whatever the
price of oil is or things like that
that's why these market signals are so
gosh darn important in the end but if
maybe sure I understand you if someone
said tell you what we'll get rid of all
your payroll taxes including Social
Security and have a carbon tax instead
you'd be ok with that no David I haven't
studied it I haven't studied it
completely but I think market mechanisms
that drive conservation ultimately are
going to be progressive for the economy
over time and whether or not that's a
great trade of I haven't really studied
that but you know I think they're gonna
they're gonna put us in a better place
over time tell us a little bit about
your experience with the subprime
mortgage market you bought WMC a few
years ago how much did you pay for that
you know we pay let's see in 2003 we run
a big financial services business we
probably have five hundred billion
dollars in assets and things like that
and in about 2003 we bought a subprime
originator called WMC in California and
it was what was called an originated to
hold
a type of business which was really
pretty much commonplace in in the last
four or five years we ran it for
probably two or three years we paid I
don't know four hundred million dollars
something like that for it when we saw
basically we tracked it very hard we saw
in the beginning in the latter part of
2006 the market began to change at the
end of the first quarter of 2007 we
basically made the decision to exit the
business and we actually the business at
that time and we probably wrote off 800
million dollars something like that as
we actually the business this was a bad
business decision you know it was it was
the wrong business at the wrong time not
the first time we've done it won't be
the last time we've done it but that's
kind of been that was the history so
what's the lesson that you learned how
do you how do you not make that mistake
again you know III would say there's two
lessons that I would learn that that I
would go after you know one is it sounds
simple one is the business model that
was underlying which we stressed that
due diligence studied for months you
know we didn't what cavalier about at
all the fundamental business decision
that you could underwrite for somebody
else to hold an asset in the end just
was flawed and so you know we should all
of the basic other businesses were in we
hold ourselves in other words we
underwrite to our own standards we hold
ourselves and this was a unique business
inside of GE Financial Services and the
other one was you know when you find
something that doesn't work X it
immediately and that's what we did here
you know basically I try to explain to
the board you can look at it one of two
ways if you're on the G board one is
Jeff and melts screwed up and cost the
company 800 million dollars and the
other one is by exiting in March we save
two billion dollars I'd prefer the
latter versus the former but
I mean I think if you run a big company
you're gonna make mistakes you know
you're gonna make mistakes every now and
then we bought Kidder Peabody in the 8th
in the 80s sold in the 90s we we got
stuck on auto loans in the late 90s we
had a private equity book in the late
night you know so again these are things
but you ask the important question is
you know at GE we tolerate we tolerate
failure but we don't tolerate a lack of
learning so basically we only let you
make the same mistake once we don't let
anybody make the same mistake twice and
that's you know that's the only way you
can run I think a successful company of
any kind so we're not going to expect
you to get back into the sub-prime I
think that's pretty safe that's pretty
safe yeah looking ahead at 2008 I know
China is gonna be very much on your mind
for a variety of reasons one of which is
that the Beijing Olympics will be taking
place there NBC will be there what and I
know that your course interested in
expanding other businesses into that
market
what ancillary benefits do you get from
having the Olympics well the Olympics is
the great global brand of all times so
you know in an NBC universe we basically
got out of all sports except for the
Olympics and football fundamental pro
football because they're just a terrible
economic equation you know it's a it's
one of these things where you know
there's there's only so many things in
life you can do as a loss leader and
sports you know Sports has a big
appetite as a loss leader the Olympics
are just a fantastic global brand their
viewership is huge for those 17 nights
you really captivate the world and if
you're a global company like ours you're
gonna and you get a natural positive
spin by being a part of the Olympics
that helps the totality of the company
so that's one that we position with we
also signed up to be an Olympic sponsor
in 2003 so the Beijing Olympics will do
about 600 million
of other gene businesses healthcare
electrical equipment things like that in
London will probably do half that three
or four hundred million dollars and
Vancouver will do a couple hundred
million dollars so we do get company
benefits now you know when I was when I
was young in 1964 the Tokyo Olympics
were really the way in which most
Americans got to see Japan for the first
time in Japan went on to become really
one of the most important countries in
my lifetime for most Americans this is
the first chance you're gonna get to see
China and I think it's going to be great
TV great theater one of the things we
were able to negotiate with the Olympic
Committee is that all of the events are
going to be televised live which
fundamentally means that the swimming
that you're gonna watch it may be 10
o'clock at night is actually gonna be 9
o'clock in the morning at Beijing so the
athletes weren't so thrilled about it
but we think it's gonna be good for a
great viewing experience for most
Americans but ok you'd like to do more
business in China and you've hung your
hat on the environmental issues here's a
country that doesn't care
well ok you know I would say a couple
things about China you know III would
say first young Chinese were your age or
just like you they want money they want
clothes they want freedom they want they
want to have access to the Internet they
want everything you want and they don't
want to live in squalor so the notion
that the Chinese people for some reason
wanna have an environment that's
horrible
that is that is dirty and stuff like
that it's just not true it's not true in
the government it's not true in the
people and it's not it's just not true
so I would say they do care they've got
a lot of work to do and and they're
gonna have to go and invest
I'd say tens of billions of dollars to
clean up China over time number one
number two David what I would say is
that they're growing their economy at
10%
here all the time that the u.s. in the
last century was growing this is their
argument okay I'm not I'm not I'm not a
want to you know be a you know give you
a political manifesto or anything like
that you know but but their point of
view is at the time in which this
country had great economic expansion we
could have cared less about about the
environment and so we used coal we did
whatever it took to grow this economy
and they want a little bit of the same
latitude that now that's that's their
point of view but I'm a firm believer
that the environment in China and India
has to be cleaned up will be cleaned up
mainly because the populations won't
tolerate it any other way
and companies like GE will be big
benefactors of those investments are you
in a position where you can put some
pressure on them you know look the basic
answer's no you know in other words
we're investors were participants we
have a lot of influence we we may have
as much influence as in any other
company but in the end we're not
political beings and and and and it's
and it's hard for us the CR will
influence how that work ultimately gets
done however the extent to which we can
be good advisors in the extent to which
we mate with the government and
politicians we very strongly endorse and
suggest that they should be working hard
on their environment and environmental
policy and we're trying to sell them
stuff well it helps to do it whether
it's coal gasification whether it's wind
energy whether it's water desalination
to be an active participant in it and
human rights activists also say you
should put pressure on China for their
activities in Darfur you know again I I
think that's only going to get more pace
as we get closer to the Olympics we've
been a big contributor to a lot of the
relief efforts in Darfur and throughout
Africa and will continue to be so to do
so I think the Olympic Committee knows
how we feel and I think the Olympic
Committee can be effective advocates for
human rights just as GE can be but
basically I'm not a politician I haven't
run for anything
and I think it would be not accurate to
assume that I carry political clout when
we go around the world the decision that
every company has to make in China is
are you going to be in or you're gonna
be out that's the decision and we can
nuance it any way we want but this is
going to be at least the second biggest
economy in my lifetime in the world and
maybe the first biggest economy in the
lifetime of everybody in this room so
you can sit on the sidelines we can talk
about how terrible everything is how
awful everything is how backwards it is
and how we wish they did this that the
other thing as a sideline character or
we get in the battle we build factories
we try to we try to establish political
ties economic ties and I think if we
don't do that progressively as a company
we're going to move back as a company
and as a country we move backwards not
forwards so you know do I agree with
everything do I like everything no but
that's you know that's probably with my
mother-in-law as well but I love her
okay and so in life you've got to make
you know you can talk about stuff you
can nuance it you can debate it but in
the end you have to say I'm either in or
I'm out
there's no half measures and if you're
in you got to be in all the way you know
and if you're not in you say goodbye to
that chapter in history you said you're
not a political person have you does
that mean you're not going to make any
contributions in the upcoming
presidential campaign you're tough today
yeah well you know my I always tell
people my my main political party is GE
I have her I have a real advocate you
know the company has always stayed
pretty bipartisan I would say and and
I've tried to be as well so I think you
know will there be contributions sure
but I would say they'll be equal he
passed this time because you haven't
picked any particular candidates at this
point no and won't and what I just think
it's not you know I'm I'm
CEO of a public company you know in many
ways the only reason why people know me
is because I run a great company and I I
don't ever want to confuse that with me
taking a public position on stuff that
fundamentally doesn't help G investors
and so I I just think that's the right
position to have if you're running a if
you're running a public company you know
so in this election one of the big
issues is health care and of course
you're one of the largest producers of
health care equipment and also a major
employer what do you think of the health
care system in the United States if I
could just broaden it a little bit you
know what I would say is that there's
two fundamental debates in this election
one is clearly national defense or act
things like that I have no particular
expertise so I put that on one side the
other one I think is broadly
competitiveness and how will the u.s.
compete in an increasingly global world
and how can we make people self
confident that we can compete and I
think and broadly competitiveness that's
about education it's about healthcare
it's about energy policy and I think
it's about tax policy that encourages
innovation so you know I think in health
care is probably of those four yet again
maybe the most complex role they're all
complex in their own way and you know I
think I think health care broadly
speaking is about 14% of the u.s. GDP
it's it's growing roughly 10% a year and
if you look at the bow wave of
demographics that are coming through in
terms of how long people are going to
live and how long the people that are
living are gonna be on the government
dole if you will it's a big challenge as
you go forward I would hope in the next
administration that they could take on
you know and it's it's one of these
things that you know like when I was a
student you know occasionally you like
in physics I would study a problem and I
would just walk away from it because was
too hard I'd say well see what the
professor has to say about this one
tomorrow you know healthcare is kind
that way you look at it and there's so
many interdependencies I think what I
would like to see happen is we've got to
do something about the uninsured mm-hmm
whoever becomes president in no.9 it's
just it's just it's it adds cost it
doesn't take cost away it's a it's the
wrong thing for our country and we have
to do something about that I think we
have to do something about the
transparency of quality metrics and have
reimbursement follow quality in terms of
outcomes and that has to be broadly
accepted you know into the system and
that I you know in anybody that's ever
run a company of any kind says as
quality gets better cost goes down and
the only industry I've ever been a part
of it doesn't measure quality
fundamentally in process quality's
health care yeah
so I think we have to do something about
that I think we have to do something
about getting information technology
broadly into the system we've got to do
something that modernizes the FDA and
makes both new technology get to market
faster but have a way to measure its
efficacy and we have to have some form
of tort reform and so what I would hope
is that the next president kind of step
you know you can look at Governor
Romney's plan of Massachusetts you could
look at Governor Schwarzenegger as plan
of California there's a there's a bunch
of plans of being involved I think all
of them have constructive aspects to it
and you know I just think whether it's a
Republican or Democrat we need to take
on a couple of these elements and get
them going forward now the last thing I
would say is health care in this country
is one of our best industries in other
words if all you did is read the
newspaper every day not the USA Today
but let's say the New York Times you'd
say that after you read the USA Today
you know you'd come to the conclusion
that every other industry in the United
States is great and the one that's
Horrible's our health care industry
because it cost too much and it's
putting this horrible burden on the
country you know health care is one of
the few export industries we have as a
country it's a place where look if we if
we do it right
I live to be a hundred China will never
catch us in health care and so we
shouldn't dismember this important
industry just because we get demagogued
and and things like that so I you know
as you as you plot your way through the
next election I think that's what's
something we got to keep in mind so now
that we've talked about healthcare let's
get to something really important how
long do you think the writers strike in
Hollywood you know it's a it's a it the
last time we've had a strike a writer's
strike was in the late 80s the strike
now has been going on for six weeks and
it's they've broken apart again the
argument is over something important you
know typically you know I've been
involved in lots of union negotiations
myself typically when things are over
things aren't important they get settled
right there's gonna be some
chest-thumping and things like that they
may go on strike for a little while but
they get settled this is about something
important which is fundamentally how the
digital revenue streams get sorted out
between you know really video kind of
content companies like NBC Universal and
the writers and directors and otherwise
and this is important you know so my
hope is it doesn't my hope is it doesn't
last too much longer
but I think the differences are profound
and to a certain extent they're worth
they're worth taking a strong stand on
if it does last will you end up losing
money or will you actually come out okay
because your costs will go down across
your program you know what I would say
is that prepare yourself for a lots of
reality TV so you know I like to put in
a plug right now for maybe five nights a
week a Deal or No Deal
like that you can get psyched for that
man I'm your I'm your guy
you know what I hope happens David
whether you know I hope the strike is
settled amicably but I think everybody
in the classic analog network business
has to rethink the business model
and I hope that this is a foundational
time when all of us really examine you
know there's there's there's this one
thing about I know some of you might be
in the business or something like that
and you might want to write this down
you can't be in businesses where the
revenues go down and the cost go up you
may want to take notes on that but but
that that almost never works okay and so
that's what's going to be reinvented now
I would say broadly speaking I'm quite
fascinated by the impact that the
internet and digital age' have in the
entertainment business and a lot of its
already taking place but to me it's it's
about it's about three things you know
it's really fundamentally about having
great content because great content
always sells the second thing you have
to do is you got to be able to
distribute content with literally dozens
of distribution notes I mean if you go
back and take a classic TV show like The
West Wing let's take a classic TV show
that many of you might be too young but
a lot of a lot of people never would
understand that might be a
billion-dollar franchise to get a
billion dollars you sell it twice you
sell advertising on air and you sell it
back in syndication get a billion
dollars if heroes turns out to be as
successful as the West Point which I
think it could be I hope it isn't does a
billion dollars we will have to have
sold at 25 times we will have to have
sold it online globally advertising in
in your Christmas stocking the last
season and so companies that have good
content and can mask the distribution
are gonna be successful the third thing
you got to figure out how you're going
to get paid you know right now we
basically use Nielsen ratings the system
we're using is about 50 years old
fundamentally and so I think what we've
all learned from Google is that you can
really get good online metrics about who
is going to be using
who's viewing your content and how it's
going to be used and I think that's all
going to take place over the next
probably three years and and and the
entertainment business is very fluid in
that regard thing but we wanted to leave
some time for questions from the
audience we have microphones on both
sides of the auditorium so if you want
to queue up there we can do that if this
don't beat don't be shy yeah just head
right up to my house sarbanes-oxley
changed your life if at all it's made it
a lot more fun you know I didn't tell
you look I think that the notion behind
sarbanes-oxley is a right-minded notion
it says basically we should have
processes in place that deliver good
results for investors and transparency
and and really it's been in place now
three or four years and I think it's
fine I think it's fine I think bar they
speaking though you know governance is
really about risk management picking
good people and having the right
strategy and so one of things I always
worry about is that investors or
business school students or things like
that think that governance is somehow
about a check the box mentality that if
you check seven boxes you're suddenly
have a company that's got good
governance that's really not true
governance is about people leadership
leadership succession it's about having
solid strategies that allow you to to
grow into the future it's about having
sound risk management principles and
keep your investors safe so don't ever
be mistaken about what really governance
is you know and that's that's the only
thing that I worry about sometimes hi
boss
I work with the commercial team for
water process technologies and I'm
applying for the MBA program here so I
was wondering if you would put a good
word for me I think you just did the
best thing you could do I hope that
mission staff is here
no I was wondering like what what
recommendation or what what's your
advice for what skills that we need to
acquire for leadership and from for you
know 10 20 years from now especially in
you know as pertains to international
business you know I I think if I would
give you a you know we teach people
inside our company on what we call
growth leadership traits and you know
and they're kind of five traits that we
drill into our people but if I try to
project it into students you know I I
would put it into maybe three basic
traits I think it's curiosity I think
it's being good with people and I think
it's being you know having perseverance
hard work thick skin things like that
are those three things are three traits
that every successful person that I've
ever known you know has in common now
what I would say about business in
general is that largely speaking I think
most of what I learned when I was young
was how to be a journal manager you know
in other words how to how to have
transportable skills how to have good
process skills kind of general
management skills things like that those
will always be important in other words
they'll never be unimportant but I
believe that successful leaders in the
next ten or twenty or thirty years are
gonna have to be real experts are gonna
have to be real domain leaders they're
gonna have to know how to pick products
they're gonna know how to pick countries
and so I really think what you should be
learning is how to develop your own
touch and feel for customers technology
innovation globalization things like
that that's gonna be a lot more
important in the next 10 or 20 years
then you know learning how to be a good
journal manager business policy or some
of those things that I learned 20 or 25
years ago I just think the world has
changed that much and and we're really
in a what and we're generation not so
much of who and how generation today
thanks a question book built to last one
of the comparisons is Westinghouse vs.
GE of course we sort of know what's
happened to Westinghouse and here in
Pittsburgh and I think a lot of the
reasons that bill class pick GE as a
good company are the things you're
continuing which is great one of the
challenges though is they talk about
culture company having to have a culture
and sticking with it and you know Jack
Welch had this policy of the sort of the
bottom 10% out every time or you know
every year and that sort of thing we
were at some benchmarking where GE
people spoke and one of the people on my
team commenting you know those guys
would play basketball to kill not in any
unethical way but just very competitive
you know every single person was very
competitive which is a good thing but
one of the things we see as a supplier
to GE over the decades is people keep
rotating through and so it's very hard
to build a steady relationship you know
as people move up again it's not leaving
GE but moving up or moving through and
what we find is people push us on price
they go to the competitor and then after
a little bit they come back because in
fact we give better service overall but
so in some ways GE is paying for that
lesson over and over again because of
the turnover and so I guess my question
to you is you you know do a number of
things right and have a good policy but
every policy or practice has downsides
what can you do or what do you think of
doing in the future to help you know
that long term memory or that lesson
learning sort of thing over time you
know again I it's hard for me to address
specific you know kind of situations
like that meant to be specific but I do
I believe it that people ought to spend
I think people ought to spend more time
some jobs you know I think one things
that I've tried to do is not have as
much churn inside the company and you
know I think it's a 125 year old company
a lot of the businesses were and we've
been in for a long time a lot of the
supplier relationships we've been in for
a long time so I think a less rotation
is a good thing but I think around
culture you know cultures change you
know in other words if I would say I
want the GE culture to evolve and change
and I would say one of the things that
makes
ge a successful company over time is
that there's probably only three
bedrocks that the company believes and
you know one is a commitment to
integrity the second one is a commitment
to performance you know in other words I
want tough minded people I like it when
we're doing an acquisition and the
counterparty complains about how tough
minded we are you know I want a
tough-minded company in a performance
word company but the last one is a real
profound commitment to change you know I
believe that we have a healthy
disrespect for history we have a healthy
disrespect for you know having people
say this is the way we used to do it we
like evolving and change and one of the
places we try to change is actually
trying to have more tenure in businesses
and jobs and I think if you look at the
median time and job just in the last
five years has grown a full year inside
the company and I think that kind of you
know domain expertise is is good but we
also want to lower price so don't forget
about that part
great thank you I think one of the
things ge is known for is its management
training program and its ability to take
young talent and mold it into leaders we
got this new Generation Y that's entered
the workforce and for many of us this is
a new generation we see coming up that
works differently that has I don't say
fundamental different beliefs but
definitely a different approach to work
can you comment on GE how you've changed
your program what you're seeing from
that that does your management program
need to change what are you facing you
know I I'll answer your question in a in
a in a blunt way but also a constructive
way you know and what I would say is it
Generation Y whatever they're called
whatever you guys are called today I've
never seen people smarter more curious
more worldly and and I think for people
that are graduating from cut you know
college is 22 year olds today I am so
optimistic about the talent that I see
and the types of people that I have and
I and I think the difference is you know
when I joined the workforce you know my
father had worked for GE actually for 40
years and my expectation was that I was
going to stay with GE you know that's
all changed in the last 25 years people
are mission driven people are mission
driven so when I come to a place like
Carnegie Mellon what I say is don't be
loyal to me you know but I say is if you
come to work for GE you're gonna be in
the front seat of history you're gonna
be in the front seat of history if you
want to see whether or not there's going
to be an electronic medical record in
the world if you want to see if there's
a cures for Alzheimer's if you want to
see whether or not biofuels becomes a
dominant energy source you can see it
here you're not gonna see it at some
startup and some of this other crazy
places you see the GE
you know so I'm gonna sell the mission I
saw the vision and the mission and I
find that generation this generation
lights the mission the other thing I
would tell Generation Y or whatever you
guys are called is that there's
generation a in India okay not B not C
not ex-nazi generation a and they want
what you have
so either with you or with them I'm
gonna build a future for GE
so in other words in other words either
with you or with them but I'm not gonna
be tonight I'm gonna go I'm gonna take
GE wherever we have to go to be
competitive and successful in the 21st
century but nobody here should be
mistaken about the fact that there's
going to be people around the world and
want everything you have they want
quality of living they want a second car
they want a vacation home they want
whatever they aspire to have you know
tickets to see the Steelers right and so
somehow between that blend of this
incredible US University graduate that I
see today that is so much smarter and
more worldly than I ever was some are
between captivating their imagination
and harnessing the hard work you're
going to find everywhere in the world
you're gonna I'm convinced that the work
force 10 years now is going to be better
than the work force today if you play
those two streams the right way thank
you okay you guys just stole my thunder
a little bit but
I'm a pediatrician who's actually back
in school at CMU earning a business
health care focus degree and I've
learned that doctors really stink at
business that was one thing but the that
my concern is the the generations II
I've been reading a lot of international
corporations they're putting a lot of
funding and support into international
education programs to look for their
future leaders if you look at the recent
scores of US students
I guess we're faring fairly poorly and
my question was does GE have a program
looking to develop leaders
internationally and where they're where
are they going to be getting their
leaders from in the next yeah you know I
would say two things first of all our
leadership programs are really global
programs so we're we're both trying to
take Americans and teach them how to be
global leaders but we're also moving
people all over the world and if you
walked into a GE Factory in China you
could eat off the floor it would have
six sigma it would have lean it would
have managers they could talk
statistical process control engineering
so everything we do in one place we do
every place else which i think is
important number one number two the Jie
foundation we give about a hundred
million dollars here maybe more to
secondary education globally a lot of
mainly in the u.s. though and this is to
get more kids in high school to study
math and science I think that's a
desperate need that we've got here and
you know like this is a the university
system the United States is the envy of
everybody in the world and and we have
fantastic you know our colleges and
university systems have no peer any
place in the world and the one big issue
I think if you could just graduate more
engineers who would study at these
places and stay in the United States
every successful country that I've ever
seen if you said what do they have in
common they graduate a lot of engineers
or they have a lot of 400 people one of
the other there's a second way to win
have a boatload of oil right but III
just totally think that you know really
you know in my mind Jerry has two jobs
want us to run Carnegie Mellon and the
other one is to make fifteen year olds
want to study engineering you know and
when you run
a place like Carnegie Mellon or MIT or
something like that you really that's to
me the biggest educational issue that
we've got in this country not enough
people that are really strong in math
and science not of kids that want to
become engineers and we got it we got to
solve that got time for one more
question you've talked about you know
working for investors how would you say
that your moral compass has been you
know affected by the decisions you've
had to make and then you have to make in
the future in regards I guess China and
just you know green energy that's a
great question look I mean I think when
you have a job like mine you you have to
make a lot of financial decisions but
you also have to make decisions where
you have to make them for a greater good
and sometimes you had sometimes they're
perfectly aligned and sometimes they're
they're more balanced and you have to
have a good moral compass about what is
what is right and what is wrong and and
be able to live with your own decisions
and you know to be honest with you I
don't find that to be that hard you know
is it hard yeah but the reason why I
studied hard when I was all of y'all's
age and things like that my my parents
are both big believers in education and
they said that if you know it's really
the great equalizer in this country and
it's a great source of self-confidence
and freedom really I mean if you have a
good education in many ways you're free
you know and and that's as far as
growing in GE as I as always place in
tough situations you know I always knew
I could get another job right
and so in the end the decisions I was
made was to do the job the way I wanted
to do it and I've I've never had to make
a compromise between doing my best
and being the type of person that I
wanted to be and at the end of the day
that's the best she can do that's the
best you can do so I think sometimes
they come to conflict but not that often
and you gotta go with your own compass
when they do
punishment closing the universe and UPS
although Thursday where Jeff Davis three
lessons three traits curiosity for the
people on perseverance real message was
if you start the business music
that fewer Marcus's father you spider
ridiculous sequence important if you are
and you communicated what question so we
have to have some other because I asked
some questions they did a great job
thank you all for being here and please
join me